buenas noches estamos de regreso para
actualizar la información en materia
económica en france 24 y lo haremos por
supuesto junto a nuestro compañero jorge
hurtado jorge muy buenas noches vamos a
hablar ahora de las causas de la crisis
te profesionales en reino unido- que
está sucediendo bueno lo que pasa es que
ahí hace falta desde carniceros para los
productos navideños hasta conductores de
cisternas para rellenar las gasolineras
del país con combustible la industria lo
adjudican al break shit y el gobierno a
un efecto de la pandemia se estima que
hay un millón de vacantes en el mercado
laboral del reino unido debido a que
muchos trabajadores de la cadena de
suministro de alimentos se quedaron sin
permisos para trabajar en reino unido-
por las nuevas reglas del presi el
gobierno propuso que esos puestos sean
sustituidos por locales pero algo que no
está sucediendo por ejemplo hacen falta
unos 100.000 camioneros y otros 15.000
carniceros entre otras industrias que ya
reportan falta de mano de obra
conversamos al respecto con jose
martinez raya él es politólogo y experto
en relaciones internacionales sobre las
causas principales de esta problemática
escuchamos que dijo
el bce supone una restricción al libre
mercado y una restricción al libre
movimiento de trabajadores entonces
antiguamente cuando el reino unido-
formaba parte del mercado único de la
unión europea en cuanto había un cambio
en la demanda queda tan sencillo como ir
a contratan país conductores o
trabajadores especializados de cualquier
país de la unión europea ese es un
proceso flexible y rápido que te
permitía absorber esos cambios en la
oferta y la demanda el problema que nos
encontramos con el bcie es que ya esa
flexibilidad desaparece esa libertad de
movimientos desaparece y también es
cierto que el reino unido ya que se ha
convertido en un país menos atractivo
que antes antes muchísima gente sobre
todo en europa del este de polonia
república checa y estos países
emigran al reino unido también incluso
de españa pues con unas buenas
condiciones de trabajo de un país
abierto
multicultural y ahora nos hemos
encontrado desde hace cinco años que se
votó el referéndum de membresía un
aumento en la xenofobia y también una
dificultad establecerse el país que lo
que ha hecho es que el reino unido sea
mucho menos atractivo para los
profesionales
congelaremos ahora de otra de las
aristas de este conflicto que tiene que
ver con que el primer ministro británico
hablamos por supuesto de boris johnson
dijo que reino unido se está encaminando
a un nuevo modelo económico bueno de
hecho sus argumentos son los bajos
salarios y la mala productividad del
modelo anterior que según él se debe a
la inmigración johnson en parte tiene
razón al señalar la baja productividad
pero eso no necesariamente es una
consecuencia de la inmigración este dato
de la organización para la cooperación y
el desarrollo económico ocde sobre el
producto interno bruto por hora
trabajada en 2019 refleja como otras
economías como francia o alemania con
altos índices de inmigración muestran
mejor productividad según un análisis de
bloomberg
otro argumento de johnson que analiza
bloomberg es respecto a la inversión
extranjera directa según el primer
ministro las nuevas medidas hará más
atractiva la inversión en su país pero
antes del pre éxito en 2016 la inversión
empresarial en general crecía a un ritmo
de 5% anual ahora se muestra a la baja
como podemos ver
lo cierto es que la crisis comienza a
golpear a las familias allí un 17 por
ciento de los británicos dicen no haber
podido comprar por falta de existencia
algunos productos básicos de
alimentación esto en las dos últimas
semanas según un dato de la oficina
nacional de estadísticas le preguntamos
a nuestro invitado qué puede hacer el
gobierno boris johnson para responder a
esta crisis
pues bueno todos sabemos que johnson y
los éxitos como los populistas culpaban
a bruselas de todos los males y decía
que recuperar el control si iba a
funcionar todo iban a recuperar todo lo
que se necesita es flexibilizar no ser
tan estrictos no aplicar este programa
de visados por puntos a la hora de a la
hora de permitir la libre pública de
trabajadores al final estamos en un
punto global y como he dicho antes el
reino unido tiene que importar gran
parte de los productos que necesitan y
también necesita trabajadores entonces
yo creo que la solución es bajarse del
carro de este heart break sheet y
reconocer que es imposible sustituir
todos los trabajadores que necesita el
reino unido por trabajadores nacionales
jorge que nos puedes decir sobre el
estado de situación de la economía de
reino unido cómo está bueno un estudio
del banco de inglaterra afirma que el
reino unido es más vulnerable a los
shocks financieros que la mayoría de las
naciones reino unido tiene más activos y
pasivos extranjeros que cualquier
economía importante y es dependiente del
comercio para el 60 por ciento de su
interno bruto- una situación bastante al
límite al límite preocupante veremos
como avanzadas jorge muchísimas gracias
por esta nueva crónica económica de
nuestra audiencia le invitamos como
siempre a continuar informando se en
france 24 y en france mit y cuatro.com
sigan con nosotros como siempre
i
[Música]